what is going on everybody and welcome
to another raspberry plying tutorial
video in this video what we're going to
be talking about is the Raspberry Pi
camera module now the camera module is
probably the easiest sensor to use with
raspberry pi since it's just super
simple plug-and-play so that's the first
one that we're going to cover and then
the next subsequent sensors are actually
going to be connected to the GPIO pins
now on the Raspberry Pi we actually have
a very specific port for the Raspberry
Pi camera module now that port is right
here now a lot of times mines actually
up already but a lot of times it will be
down so to open the port there's these
two tabs on the side you can grab those
and pull up and that opens up the port
now go ahead and connect the Raspberry
Pi and generally like the backside of
this pin of the ribbons rather is this
like silver pins and then on the other
side you've got the covered blue that
blue should be facing towards the the
Ethernet port so go ahead and take the
ribbon and insert it in it should just
slide in like like this into the port
and then when it's in there you can't
have to hold it with one hand then use
your other hand to push down the pins
it's kind of hard to see you with this
in the way anyways you hold it with this
hand you push down and then use your
other two fingers to push down on the
pins
once that's done that's really all there
is to it now your camera is connected
and we're ready to actually plug in the
Raspberry Pi and see the results okay so
now the Raspberry Pi is plugged in what
I'm going to go ahead and do is change
directory into desktop and I'm going to
create a new file here you can do this
via the remote desktop but the main
issue here is that it's going to want to
display on the route the actual PI like
when we display video now you could
process video and all that but if you
actually want to display video you're
not going to see the video via remote
desktop and you're certainly not going
to see it on a non GUI show so I'll just
show the monitor when it
when it comes up but this if you want to
see the actual preview of the video it's
got to be on the native screen at least
as far as I know so what we're going to
go ahead and do now is come over you
know go to the desktop and first we have
to actually enable the camera so sudo
rasp I - config and this is going to
require a reboot actually now come down
to interfacing Options hit enter their
cameras the first option and go ahead
and hit yes to enable the camera and
you're done
and then hit finish and mine's already
been enabled so I don't need to reboot
but chances are you're going to need to
reboot so go ahead and reboot and then
once you do log back in and then once
you log back in don't forget to see
desktop desk well I'm already good but
anyway okay so now what we're going to
do is we're going to create a new file
I'm going to call this nano camera
example dot PI and in here we're going
to do some imports we're going to import
PI camera PI camera and then we're going
to import time and just to be a 100
percent certain I'm actually going to
control X Y s to save yes it should be
sudo apt-get install Python - I can
possibly let's see if that works ok yeah
Python - my camera alternatively it
could be also Python 3 - my camera but
we have both anyway getting back into
camera example PI Nancy I'm getting
tossed nano Cameron - yes ok now we're
going to find the camera object which
will just be PI camera PI camera and
then we can do camera first let's take a
quick picture so camera capture and then
let's just save it as example dot JPEG
and let's go ahead and in fact kind of
want to go into any pauses for a moment
I guess we'll go we actually will login
to the remote desktop because I'm the
picture we should be able to see it's
just going to be the video feed that's
not going to work for us remotely I'll
hit OK and I'll just kind of have both
of these up we I could go to that
computer over there I just there's no
way real good way for me to record that
screen so I just don't like to
anyway I'll move this over and let's
actually just run this real quick so
python camera example dot pi and we
should now have yes example dot jpg
we'll come up to the remote desktop we
can click on it and there i am giving
you this lovely lovely tutorial okay so
now let's go ahead and close that and
this time we can see that well the image
was actually flipped upside down so we
can go back camera example and what we
can say instead is it will just do it
above here camera D flip evils true so
that will actually flip the camera
vertically you can also do a horizontal
flip if you wanted so yes and let's run
that again and then come back to the
remote desktop click on the image and
there we go a right-side up fantastic
alright next what we're going to do is
we can do a record so we can go python
or nano camera example we don't need to
capture again this time let's do a
camera dot start recording and then
we'll just save this as example vid to
six four will do it i'm not sleep five
and then let's do camera that's
stop recording and that will save the
file so we've got a five second video so
we'll go ahead and start that recording
process and then when we're done we're
going to use the omx player you should
already have this in your on your PI so
let's come over here let me open the
terminal and we're not in desktop so
it's change directory to the desktop and
now we can do is just call a MX player
omx layer what do we call that video I
already forgot I think is an example of
it or something example of it if there
it is
hit enter and it's playing I think on
the other I didn't see it pop up here
yeah so you should see it on your own
but let me just fullscreen this and then
we can play that one more time and there
we go so there's the the video that we
recorded so for whatever reason is just
for show on the remote desktop okay so
that's just some quick basics you can
also get just a camera feed like the
actual preview so for example we could
just run Python real quick from my
camera we're going to import PI camera
we're going to set camera equals camera
and then camera dot start underscore
preview this may or may not work my
camera's still showing that it's on for
some reason we'll see now it looks like
it's gone we didn't need the vertical
flip but regardless it's actually so
[Music]
anyway okay that should be enough for
the camera module you do all kinds of
stuff with it you can do
[Music]
we pull up the see the opencv another
robotics one yes yes yes yes so what you
can do with this all kinds of stuff of
course but you can program a robot to
shoot missiles at you when it sees your
face so that's always fun anyway
hopefully get your camera working if you
have any problems questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise in the next few
tutorials what we're gonna be doing is
talking about the actual GPIO pins on
the Raspberry Pi and doing some pretty
cool stuff with that so that's what you
guys have to look forward to I will see
you another tutorial